I'm let put in sign f90 - now you can of
course do the same thing we did before
and instead of 90 you can choose a
variable value you can slide it around
you can see its effect I will do that in
a second but before I do that let's just
put it so there's 90 - X so from the
graph want the mysteriously should say
90 degrees minus X I'm getting the same
graph I got for Part A anti it's cause X
right it's close it okay now why is this
case why is this the case because you
have to understand what's going on I'm
going to give you two explanations one
is a simple one which is actually
rehearsal of a previous explanation I
gave you which is fine I hope will
convince you but it's not enough which
is why I'm going to go into the second
explanation the second explanation
I'll warn you right now it's harder but
it will yield you more insights if you
take the time and effort to understand
it okay
ready explanation number one simple here
we go right angle triangles that's where
treat begins right so if I plot X over
here okay and what's the label outside
shall we display angle so I'll make it a
B and C just like Pythagoras okay on
this diagram because it's right angle
this angle up here is 90 degrees minus X
content with that okay so here sine of
this angle which is sine of 99 steps is
opposite on hypotenuse B on C and in
exactly the same way cos of X which is a
different angle is adjacent on
hypotenuse so it's also equal to B on C
okay so there's my argument these two
are equal and this is why but I wonder
if you can see why this is not enough of
an idea to take forward do you remember
why we are introduced the unit circle
think
a few lessons why do we do that okay so
we had quadrants we had negative angles
we had angles that are bigger they can
fit in a triangle right this argument
here is only justified for acute values
of X as it happens it looks like it's
true for all of them
I look it's it's cosine all the way it's
not like it's cosine sometimes and then
it changes rules so we need a better
more sophisticated way to demonstrate
this okay so here's the way I'm going to
get let's start with this sine of 19 -
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to try and bring together some of
the knowledge we have and apply that to
this okay 90 minus X this is a bit funny
this is about funny if I wrote this in
the correct order it would look like
this okay now you're like well what's
the difference the difference is it
makes it clear what's happened to the X
and which direction the shift is going
okay so think about this hey try this if
i graph this and now I'm gonna go into
my up slider you might like to follow me
okay I'm gonna graph this guy's minus X
plus a okay now if you go back right
what just happened there like this sine
of minus X I haven't added the shift in
yet what is this thing hmm they have to
be careful because this thing is
symmetrical a couple of different things
look like they're happening but really
only one thing is happening of sine of
minus X that - there - sines what they
mean is opposite direction + and + and -
okay when you apply it to an X that
means flip horizontally if you were to
apply it to a why it would mean flip
vertically okay but the thing is because
this function has symmetry because it
said what kind of function what kind of
what
she doesn't have it's an odd function
because it's an odd function that's
that's what my next guess is gonna be if
I flip horizontally which is what I've
done right it's gonna look exactly the
same as to if I flipped it vertically
you see that the blue graph is the red
graph upside down and I can take
advantage of that I know that this is
equal to minus sine X remember we were
talking about odd and even functions and
we said this sine of minus x equals
minus sine of X that's what defines an
odd function okay all right I'm gonna
come back to doing this shifting my -
there and I'm going to add so let's add
a slider engine and let's make these
values a little more helpful zero to 360
steps of 50 okay so what do you expect
to happen this is the blue graph right
this is the blue graph and it's a plus
it's a plus so which way is it gonna go
hold on a second
because his name what's happening what's
happening you have to think about this
very carefully let me do it again just
so you can convince yourself of what's
actually happening when I move it this
way what's going on it's going to the
right let's just let's just see that
it's going to the right but we we just
laid the point before that if I give you
this right I give you this this should
go to the left
shouldn't it so what what's really going
on this is very very sneaky okay I'm
gonna show you I'll show you see this
right I'll just let that keep doing its
thing content this is bit sneaky what it
really is is this now you're like what
what just happened just happened
shame on this - Sun right it's taking
everything in here and it's flipping it
round flipping around okay then this
moves you in what direction
so your funny joke about that me and
remind me okay this is going to the
right it's going to the right okay it's
supposed to go to the right X -
something is a right word ship it's a
positive shift okay so this minus sign
out the front is flipping the whole
thing and then this minus 90 is moving
me to the right okay so now let me just
lock it in it you pause it and bring it
back to 90 there it is
so it was flit and then it moved its
flipped and been a movement okay
however because that means it was moving
in the opposite direction
right that's just like the first graph
we were doing which ended it cause right
so that's why I'm will no surprise that
these two graphs a and B are gonna give
you exactly the same graph so Zack kind
of make a little bit of sense play with
it a little more explore it I could make
you like I just turn these out and
that's how I got the understanding but
it's so much better when you can
actually move the back of them and see
what's going on all right let's have a
look at Part C we can do this a bit
quicker now that we've done some of the
hard ones okay let's do this so we'll do
this really quickly I'm gonna make my
original graph cause there's cause and
then I'm going to put on there which one
okay so sorry what it did was the minus
sign flips things around horizontally
but this minus ninety moves things to
the right because the minus is applied
to X values not to not to my Y values so
let me let me show you this way okay
let's uh we'll go with them okay if I
said to you cos of X you know what that
looks like
it's that okay in fact listen there you
go they go now if I compare that to cos
of minus X pause what's it going to do
how would you Ferb Eliezer and it's up
there's a flip happening and it's
happening to the horizontal direction
right and so sure enough you ought to
expect because cos is an even function
there he is and they're on top of each
other because these two graphs are the
same right
no that was in one direction okay here
let's go in the other direction now we
usually say why is the subject that's
the normal way we write equations y
equals his wife was that so if I gave
you this
you wouldn't bat an eyelid right except
this kind of clouds what's going on this
- isn't really over here a more helpful
place to put it is over here because
this clarifies what's being flipped
tell me what's being flipped it's going
vertically right which is why sure
enough when you graph right - why you
can just cause the X like this biz - -
cause it's the red graph lift vertically
upside down okay so what you put the
minus sign on affects what you're
flipping and here the minus signs are
all the X's they don't even touch the
Y's they're not even close
okay so that's what's happening in here
and then X minus 90 shifts it to the
right that's what we saw when we might
remember them okay and in fact if I
changes to a hundred or hundred and
twenty it's gonna go further and further
to the right it doesn't get flipped it
gets flipped